hello and welcome
it is January 31st 2023 we're here in
octave bookstream number
1.08 off to you blue
so we will be discussing this book
continuing our discussion of this book
governing continuous transformation by
Jean kesri we are the active inference
Institute
participatory online Institute that is
communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can reach
us at all of our social media links this
is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work all backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome here and we will be
following good video etiquette for live
streams
um again if you would like to
participate in this project or any
activities that are ongoing in the
active inference Institute please reach
out to us there are plenty of ways to
get connected and involved
um okay so the goal of today's
bookstream is to continue our discussion
of this book
um and we will just be going through it
as usual um just as always this is not a
review or a final word over this
material just as an introduction to some
of the ideas
um okay so just quick introductions for
those of you who don't know us I am blue
Knight I've been involved in the active
inference Institute for quite a while
I'm an independent researcher in New
Mexico and I'll pass it off
Daniel
hi Daniel I'm a researcher in California
I'll pass to the title
my name is Tyler I'm a critical designer
and GAP researcher in California
right
So today we're moving on to chapter
eight of the book uh the title of this
chapter it's in part two the free energy
governance section and the title of this
chapter is capabilities Duality
management and we'll talk more
um in as we go on as as to what Duality
management kind of means
um okay so there are two sections
outlined by Bijan here in this chapter
there are Dynamic capability View and
antagonistic neural networks perspective
there's a whole bunch of keywords and
we'll just jump right into it um Tyler
do you want to read this part of the
abstract for us
sure all right so abstract Dynamic
capability view GCV and antagonistic
neural networks perspective A and P
address free energy governance
capabilities Dimension the board's
cognitive capabilities in terms of meta
managing
interdependently opposing Logics as
Unity are increasingly relevant to
continuous strategic renewal Duality
management such as the vacillation
between exploitation and adverse
exploration and balancing financials
profusion control is established as a
dynamic board capability effectively FEG
extends dcv to the board level more
importantly by adopting a free energy
principle power perspective by
redefining the firm as an inactive
inference machine dcb's triplet of
sensing seizing and reconfiguring S has
this operationally such that the firm is
engaged as a whole
great so
antagonistic neural network perspective
is established and applied as the
neuroscientific basis for Duality
management managing the existing while
contradicting the present to develop the
future this task positive Network slash
uh what is the other one
gmn Dynamic mode Network I can't
remember uh antagonism what is it
default mode Network there it is
um default mode Network antagonism
between exploitative task execution and
explorative explorative abductive
thinking is a neurological
representation of the contradictory
demands that challenges companies
sustainable outperformance and survival
the board is traditional monitoring and
advisory roles must be explicitly
complemented with The Duality management
mandate
um managing both of these networks more
specifically the board's Dynamic
capability of Duality management lays
the foundation for the board's newly
established governance purpose and
discontinuous and distributive
distributed markets quote Duality
stewardship
um yeah and so we'll get into these task
positive and default mode networks as we
get in later to this presentation
all right
um so this is a dynamic capability view
I looked it up I found this cool image
um so Bijan says sensing strategic
opportunities in Dynamic Market
environments seizing the opportunity and
reconfiguring a firm's resource base
accordingly are a dynamic capabilities
use three Central pillars and he cites
this reference
um so here we see these
fencing seizing and managing or I guess
that's reconfiguring
um
these are the three pillars and then
they give some micro foundations like
what is this sensing seizing
reconfiguration or managing threats
um so I don't know Tyler do you have any
like thing to add here or maybe like
specific examples
um I I mean I see like I I to me this is
a very abstract like diagram and I'm
like what's going on here
yeah I mean I think
this makes it more seem more difficult
and complicated than it really is where
a lot of times with sensing a lot that's
where there's like that abductive
reasoning we're saying like hey there's
something here what could be true here
like how do I explain kind of this like
these disparate signals I'm getting from
the environment how do I make sense of
this and where seizing is like actually
building the thing and managing
Progressive performing is like managing
that thing you built over time and I
think you actually in the next slide it
gives a really good example with um
Amazon Kindle I've actually maybe if you
could just go to the next slide I think
it um explains it well
so for example it says for example
Amazon's launch of the Kindle 2006
involves sensing and the impending
threat of its Core bookselling Business
it's using the opportunity through Rapid
development of the first generation
eBook reader and gradually reconfiguring
its internal activities to ensure that
the Kindle became an integrated part of
its overall Market offering
thanks thank you
um uh bishan goes on to say in a similar
manner to that in which organizational
Learning Resource research distinguishes
between single Loop and double Loop
learning capability research also
distinguishes between operational
capabilities and dynamic capabilities
and so um in the text he gives some
examples of like operational
capabilities like mergers and
Acquisitions and other like things that
are outside the scope of this Dynamic
capability View
um okay so start reading these claims so
he says there has lately been a shift in
Dynamic capability view from behavioral
to cognitive interpretations explicating
the cognitive micro foundation's
underpinning thesis 2007 Three core
pillars of dynamic capabilities sensing
perception seizing sense making and
asset configuration language
communication and social cognition so
this is like reframing again those those
three pillars kind of more towards the
active inference of free energy
governance perspective
um he was on to say with respect to
Dynamic managerial capabilities for
seizing and reconfiguring in particular
we have emphasized ways in which top
management can shape aspects of the
organizational context such as by
encouraging cooperation lowering
resistance to change designing a
business model for a new Venture and
investing in new skills and assets this
suggests that managerial cognitive
capabilities May function as mediators
of the relationship between changes in
organizational context and strategic
change which in turn can affect firm
performance
do either of you guys have any comments
here should we move to the next one okay
all right so I had to look this up
because the term industrial vertical was
like brought up and I was like what is
industrial vertical um and I think like
it's more commonly called an industry
vertical you could have it like in the
industrial field and then it's like
something different but an industry
vertical is also known as a vertical
market and it's like a unique business
Niche that serves a specific set of
consumers or customers and their
particular needs and there's like tons
of examples of that like I don't know
organic food and I don't know like
solutions for a biology lab or like
there's you know all these like Niche
markets and and it's like if you're
trying to sell chemicals to a biology
lab like you know you're selling them
like hplc purified acetic acid and like
you're not selling that acetic acid to
you know someone to use in their kitchen
for salad dressing like it's a totally
different like even though you're
selling acetic acid those are two
totally different markets of people so
you don't want to make a product that's
like bought by everyone because then it
actually is not useful for anyone that
was kind of my understanding do you have
anything to add Tyler yeah it makes it
could give like a little more color of
examples here just like an example of an
industry vertical could be like movie
making business or like on the top end
you might have like where the movies are
consumed it's a movie theater and then
you have how it's produced so you have
Studios you have screenwriters uh you're
the people who are actually creating the
equipment and making the film right so
it's basically like this big kind of
almost supply chain or these
interrelated businesses that are all
supporting each other to one
um final product so I one thing I would
add here too that I think the Jean would
probably agree with is that in a more
discontinuous world the idea of an
industry vertical is becoming a little
bit more fuzzy and so for example like
in the past you might say like well I
have this I make research I make
chemicals for biology research right but
it could be the case that you also make
chemicals that are used for like hair
products and so like your verticals are
increasingly becoming more fuzzy and
intertwined and it becomes harder to
think about like like where do I
actually like what Niche do I actually
serve like
what is the market I'm in right and it
could be really hard to think that and
that's where sensing really comes in
handy is because you could be like oh
well I thought I was making biology
research chemicals but it turns out
because I've I'm sensing and using my
adductive reasoning and when they've you
know my best fpg perspective I can I'm
actually in the hair care market and
that's where I really should be
um and so it's kind of the idea of a
really cool becomes harder to Define uh
over time
this website actually gave a lot of
examples about how uh like industry
verticals allow companies that would
sometimes be competitors to
um collaborate with each other like they
talked about how the Samsung glass is
used by the Apple iPhone or maybe it's
the other way around but either way like
Samsung and like the Samsung phones and
the Apple phones are normally like you
know competitors in a market
um I don't even know that they compete
anymore like either you're a Mac person
or you're an Android person like I don't
think that there's any competition there
but maybe
um
so but how the you know they're
collaborating with the use of the glass
and making it accessible to everyone
just because everybody needs glass right
um okay so they also Bijan also brought
up um oh yeah here is the industrial
vertical so let me read this from the
from the book it says indeed
independently of industrial vertical the
increasingly distributed and
discontinuous nature of Market
transforming forces cannot be
overestimated however Market velocity
velocity is too generic of a concept and
so like I was trying to understand
um
like how he was using the term Market
velocity like here and like so Market
velocity like when you Google it it's
like it indicates the level of Market
activity in individual NASDAQ stocks by
measuring the frequency and share volume
in aggressively priced orders it can
indicate changes in Market Direction
momentum or liquidity in each stock
enabling users to imply future price
movements And Trades so like that's how
like Fast the Market's moving I guess
um and then like it's also a company
that recycles and like velocity is a
measure of two Dimensions right the
speed of change and the change in
Direction so I don't know
um like the concept of Market velocity
here like he can he goes on to compare
it to environmental scarcity so the more
suitable
um Dynamic capability concept is
environmental scarcity uh inspired by
Cameron and zamuto 1983 meaningfully
relating sensing and sense making as
meta capabilities respectively to
econation Dynamics and strategic renewal
so I don't know um like how
environmental scarcity and Market
velocity like how those two relate to
each other I don't know if you guys can
offer any insight here
um but this is something that like I
would hold out and ask John about
yeah I think with with Market velocity
like a lot of times when people talk
about discontinuities and like like
people who are not coming from an fpg
background I'm talking about hey like
things are moving really quickly
it's more uncertain than ever they talk
about Market velocity right like things
are just changing all the time and I
think what vagina is saying is like
just saying that things are changing
very quickly isn't very helpful to you
because you're like okay cool like life
is hard I get it like now what do I do
with that information where when you
presents environmental scarcity it's
becoming a little bit more specific and
like how you can actually be more action
oriented with it because you're like
okay well like what's my Niche and what
are the meta capabilities I have to to
create to manage this uncertainty and
create my own Niche uh whereas Market
velocity is kind of like being
overwhelmed by uncertainty and being
like I don't know things are hard like
this is scary
that's at least my take
so she goes on to um oh sorry go ahead
one related angle to connect back to
what we've discussed elsewhere is this
concept of generalized coordinates which
is the value that something is at and
then the first derivative which is the
velocity and then the acceleration
higher derivatives and so on and so that
allows you to track one variable like
the temperature or the salinity of the
water or the funds in the bank account
and look at it not just where it is but
how fast it's moving and how fast it's
changing how fast it's moving and then
you can learn certain things like oh the
third derivative is always within this
range so that puts certain bounds on
timelines that the primary indicator
might change by a certain amount or not
and we see some of those things like um
the gradual decline sudden decline those
are differentiated not by their starting
point but by the rate of their decline
so velocity is something that we can
talk about in Bayesian physics actually
as a speed
um and then he goes on to outline this
environmental scarcity
um from this Schmidt at Al 2016
reference which says combining the type
and rate of decline allows us to
distinguish four environmental scarcity
situations environmental dissolution
which is the gradual decline in shape
environmental erosion gradual decline in
size
environmental collapse sudden decline in
shape and environmental contraction
sudden decline in size so like I was
trying to like picture this as like a
like a
um I don't know maybe like a market
right like and so like the market
changes shape like what would it mean
for a market to change shape really
um I get like the market changes size
like all of a sudden you know there's
not a market for CDs anymore because
everybody's listening to mp3s so like
that's like a
um
well I guess like that's a change in
shape and size I'm not sure how to
really think so so to use that example
like that would be a change in shape
where like for example imagine the same
and number of people were listening to
music but the format changed so it's
like the the market is music people who
listen to music but the shape is a
little bit different of like how they're
consuming it whereas it could be a try
to change its size and shape as if like
you move to mp3s now because it's MP3s
more people can access the music the
market grows and that'd be a change of
size and shape
or like the market totally disappears
because we can just stream whatever we
want on YouTube now like yeah exactly
that's like that's also a change in size
and shape I guess
um but yeah okay cool all right so uh
environmental scarcity is more suitable
than Market velocity and I guess I can
see why that that is because it it's
more nuanced as to like what is actually
changing is it just like up or down and
how fast or like the shape and the size
um and like the rate I guess all of that
is is taken into this environmental
scarcity concept
um okay uh do you want to read these
claims Tyler
sure so while slow and gradual Market
changes tests in particular our sensing
capability more certain changes
challenging firms sense making
capability uh there's really is no
objectively uncertain Market environment
uncertainty is an ad for dependent
mental experience facing one's very
limitations of dynamic AirPlay between
sensing and sensor making therefore
independent of the degree of Market
philosophy Dynamic capabilities are
critical he goes on to say the stronger
and setting the impact of environmental
scarcity the higher the urgency to act
and hence the stronger the tendency for
strategic renewal to be rather Financial
control center I M A and other forms of
alliancing precisely for two reasons one
these the existing resource base is too
trapped in the past to unlearn Advanced
renewal from within and without or to
the opportunity for Market consolidation
is too irresistible and as JP Morgan Had
demonstrated during the 2007-2008
financial crisis and time to action is
critical
cool
um so yeah I guess that that kind of
sheds more light on the environmental
scarcity
um concept here
uh okay so just I wanted to Define this
we kind of talked about the tyranny of
the ore
um last time but we didn't really
elaborate on it and so we we last time
we talked about this good to Great to
Gone book um Circuit City and uh the
tyranny of the ore is actually um Bijan
keeps quoting this wurtzel book about
the tyranny of the Lord but I had to
like look it up it's actually from the
not good to Great Jim Collins book but
like another Jim Collins book that I
haven't read uh built to last and so
here the tyranny of the ore is the
rational view that cannot easily accept
Paradox that cannot live with two
seemingly contradictory forces or ideas
at the same time the tyranny of the ore
pushes people to believe that things
must be either A or B but not both
um and so I think that this concept kind
of goes like is like a light
introduction and we'll dive deeper into
it about like Duality and Duality
management like being able to hold two
simultaneously
um opposing or maybe seemingly opposing
or necessarily contradictory opinions
and reviews
ah okay and here we go right into uh
Duality management
um so Vision says in fact at any point
in time a firm is challenged to balance
strategic organic r d driven Innovation
and growth with financial control
external growth and Innovation by way of
forms of strategic partnering there is
no tyranny of War it is The Duality a
continuous balancing act that is
mutually reinforcing and with
perspective and time and space forms a
Unity free energy governance establishes
Duality management as a dynamic
capability specifically as a dynamic
board capability Duality management such
as vacillation of exploitation versus
exploration and balancing financial and
strategic control is established as a
dynamic board capability the
goal-directed action-centric and
generative circular causality of
top-down bottom-up and lateral sense
making processes prediction error
minimization forms the basis for
leveraging opposing Logics in the form
of duality
um and Duality Management in contrast
with uh strategy management do you want
to read this one Tyler
sure so indeed strategy management has
traditionally embraced one environmental
co-creation versus co-alignment two
exploitation of the first exploration
and three Financial for strategic
control as dualism or Paradox rather
than as Duality it's the background of a
world that is increasingly distributed
just continuous and in this capability
interdependent persistence persistency
and contradiction of interdependent
elements which is the defining core
Paradox it's potentially nonsense and
therefore severely limits the
theoretical as well as practical
relevance of a strategic Paradox lens
foreign
you know the old way and as opposed to
Duality management which is
um the new way
do you guys have anything to add here
this is kind of like Paradox is
attention to balance
Unity is plural and at minimum two
rather than Paradox or something that
must be resolved one way or the other so
it's really compatible with a lot of
qualitative things people say about
wisdom and balance and I think the
question will be how is that enacted in
organizations and how does that connect
to active
yeah I mean one thing that's interesting
about Duality management is that there's
also like a strong cultural tendency to
be decisive or a biased to be decisive
um in that like the perception of kind
of
going not wanting to make a choice can
be seen as weak
um whereas like you haven't really so
like there's even if I think a lot of
people would recognize The Duality and
say like yeah like I don't know it's
kind of both like you want to explore or
you want to exploit like I think a lot
of people would would recognize that but
when you're in a meeting and you're not
like really committing to something well
you're not like really a lot of people
feel like they're not really offering
Like A New Perspective like they're not
putting their stake in the ground saying
like this is where I how I feel about it
and this is where I'm gonna like you
know push behind uh and so I feel like a
lot of people feel this pull to like
make a call and so that's one like even
at an executive level you can feel that
especially two-year like on the
executive level and even if you
recognize this Duality and you're
communicating what you want to do to the
broader organization like Duality is a
really hard thing to communicate and say
like yeah we don't really know what's
going on like it could be one of these
multiple things like let's figure it out
together I have done this look I have
like communicate this before it's A Hard
Road to go down right we're like hey
yeah we're all just figuring it out like
it's gonna be like let's just kind of be
fluid about it a lot of people don't
like to hear that because it sounds like
well this person doesn't know what
they're doing and I don't even like know
where we're going this is really scary
um and so I do want to touch on this
later but like it's one thing
recognizing duality in yourself and on a
small management team how you talk about
duality in a broader organization
there's like a whole different animal
um and so I hope we can talk about that
more a little bit later
yeah thanks for that
uh okay so um we talked last time also
about
um like the quantum Duality and like
what what does patreon mean and like we
knew that he would really kind of
um unwrap it here in this chapter so um
I I guess like we've seen Duality like
we
um are able to like hold simultaneously
it's simultaneously a one and a zero and
so we were wondering if if uh what was
really meant by Duality like in the
quantum sense was more like the
superposition
um angle and so it it seems like yes
um uh based on even this quote from the
book sober Jean says it is important to
appreciate that many dichotomies that
have Divine defined the science and
practice of strategy management such as
firm versus environment executive
leadership versus non-executive Board
individual versus firm exploitation
versus exploration Financial control
versus strategic control formal versus
informal channels and flexibility versus
stability for example are less and less
dichotomous in a distributed and
discontinuous world but coexist in
superposition as Duality or
synchronicity
so I think that this kind of maybe
answers at that question for us from
last week
if you guys have any comments here
okay
so oh Daniel
yeah some of those dualities are raised
as a partition like firm from
environment or organism versus
environment it's a partition that is an
integrated whole and so that is part of
this framing question seeing it as an
integrated unit but also containing
um separate aspects and then also
Quantum carries a lot of baggage whether
somebody's familiar with what it
technically means or not dualities in
the quantum space could refer to wave
particle it could refer to Observer
observed and so I think it needs a lot
more operationalism to have utility
Beyond a sort of like evocative Quantum
management and then again to come back
to Tyler's point which I want to hear
more about
um
if you say well we're actually doing all
the strategies it's like a wave you
thought we were going to go to one
strategy or the other we're going to be
probabilistic across all of them how
does that work
Tyler I'm waiting for your comeback oh
well I mean honestly like
I have actually strategy of how I do
this and I just don't necessarily
communicate broadly that we're doing oh
the strategy is probabilistically like
like I might know that and maybe a
couple other people know that we're like
kind of like keeping our options open
for a bunch of different Avenues but you
communicate something that's much more
clear
um you can't I don't think you get to do
both but you don't get to communicate
that broadly
it's just not consumable by other people
and it doesn't give them like it's not
really actionable by them so you can't
say we're doing all the strategy there
because they're like cool then how do I
fit into this you have to say like well
this is broadly what we're doing and
this is how you're going to fit into it
um and so yeah
also action helps cut this knot so for
any given search space it's not possible
to have one parameter value that is
maximizing exploitation and exploration
that gets into the sort of like I'm
everywhere on the number line at once
type thinking but action allows us to
say well our strategy is we're going to
move quick but as soon as criteria one
two and three are met then we're going
to lock in so that's actually a plan
that you can have Precision about that
embodies in a another variable space
explore exploit but where we have
Precision about
is about action which is what his whole
emphasis is on
actually and that reminds me another
strategy I use too is that you
explicitly frame it around exploration
and that like you're waiting for
something to exploit so you're saying
like hey all right we're going to build
this thing and we're not sure like who's
gonna even use this right but we're able
to say we have a hypothesis that these
kinds of people might use it and then
we're gonna see who uses it and that's
like the experiment we're running
together as a company is this like
Define scope explore stage and then once
we run that experiment then we move to
exploit and so you can like kind of like
clearly do that within an organization
of like how you're switching between
these different modes
nice
okay uh Bichon says therefore to
effectively operationalize Dynamic
capabilities triplet of sensing seizing
and reconfiguring we need a model that
dynamically links Dynamic capabilities
triplet with the environment this is
free energy governance is underlying and
active inference one active States
acting sensing two sensory States
perception sensing sense making and
seizing the opportunity and three
internal States firm resources resource
configuration and four external States
unknown hidden are all Linked In
circular causality conditioned by the
internal external Markov blanket and
governed by free energy minimization and
so I just thought it was interesting
here like we can go back and look here
at the three pillars like
um the sensing seizing and like
reconfiguring and like for me like the
sensing part
um like goes here like in this action
sensing or sensing is like in sensory
States but like seizing the opportunity
as a sensory State like totally threw me
off
um like is it just me like a sensory
like sensing the opportunity is like one
thing but like leveraging an opportunity
as like a sensory State like that seems
more like an action State I don't know
if it's just me or like what you guys
think about that
um because I was kind of like whoa
seizing the opportunity is a sensory
state
well for example in seizing he included
like creating your business model
and so that is I think part of sense
making because you're like this is how
we relate to the ecosystem so it's like
action like this action centered because
there's also sensory or something like
well this is the kind of like
information that we're going to collect
from the environment as well
and so I think you're kind of doing both
the action and perception
when you're doing season here so like
this is how I'm going to relate to my
environment
um
not sure if that's exactly was what you
were saying I think this is a attempt to
coerce for better and For Worse a
triplet
into the particular partition
where blankets are defined as graph a
Bayesian graph where there are nodes
that make two other sets of nodes
conditionally independent and I think
we've seen in the philosophical and
application settings a lot of challenges
with people simply coercing a
naturalistic understanding of how things
are in the world with this Bayesian
graph formulation like here we have
active States action sensing
action states are the outgoing
statistical dependencies of an entity so
yeah they are action and if you think
about active sensing then they're sort
of elusively related to sensing but it's
not a sense State and so how much are we
going to have both feet in the technical
formalism of the particular partition
and to what extent are we kind of
leaving one foot on the formalism and
then pivoting around and trying to draw
in some other Frameworks and draw
concordances
so I I agree that it's like a coerced
um like like put moving the triplet into
this like particular partition but I I
just don't know if seizing the
opportunity is something that I would
include as a sensory State
um I I think that that's something that
I would put like even in constructing a
business plan like that's still an
action that you'd like Take On The World
so so that's something that's outgoing
not something that's necessarily
incoming and that's just how I would
frame it
um or like the way that made more sense
to me so I just found this a particular
like a particularly curious
um area to to put it
um but yeah we can move on and talk
about we can ask me John why he put it
there uh hopefully and then we can talk
about this antagonistic neural networks
perspective
um so Bhajan says antagonistic neural
network perspectives is established and
applied as the neuroscientific basis for
Duality management managing the existing
while contradicting the present to
develop the future it is the form of
organizational learning that Strategic
Management literature has labeled
ambidexterity co-managing exploitation
and exploration
in neuroscientific terms the
antagonistic relationship is between two
large-scale cortical networks the task
positive Network tpn and the default
mode Network dmn which simply put our
neuroanatomical representations of top
Management's day-to-day task specific
focus on exploitation the task positive
Network on the one side and the rather
non-routine Divergent and creative
thinking that initiates exploration and
strategic renewal the default mode
Network
um and so I thought this was super
interesting and took like a deeper dive
into like looking up the reference for
that uh quote
um and so here in this paper
antagonistic neural networks underlying
differentiated leadership roles by boys
and uh rashford and Jack they say the
antagonistic relationship between the
test positive Network and the default
mode Network creates a fundamental
neural constraint on cognition that is
highly relevant relevant to the
different roles and capabilities that
effective leaders must astutely juggle
and deploy an important consequence of
this constraint is that an over emphasis
on task-oriented leadership can prove
deleterious to an organization in
particular when openness to new ideas
people emotions and ethical concerns are
important to success on the other hand
the over emphasis on
relationship-oriented leadership may
prove deleterious to focus and and the
execution of clearly defined goals and I
thought that this was really cool I just
have never like
thought about leadership like this but
it's definitely there's like the people
component and like the GSD component
like getting stuff done
um and and like leadership requires both
and like you can't like you need to have
both and I also thought like that the
ambidexterity here like where Bishop
talks about is like interesting because
like you think about like organizations
and you always hear like the phrase like
the left hand doesn't know what the
right hand is doing and I wonder if like
that's why this is like uh this
different management
um like role or dichotomy is like
labeled like the ambidexterity or like
what what which which came first the
chicken or the egg here
um I don't know to get through any
comments here
one thing I thought was interesting here
is like you know one level there's like
this analogy between like the default
mode Network and the test positive
network with we might find in an
organization
but I've always was interesting too was
thinking about how the individual
relates to the organization and that
like you know the the creativity that an
individual or leader can exercise is
kind of constrained by the antagonistic
relationship between their own test
positive and default mode Network right
and you know it's one thing for people
to say like yes like you need to have
this antagonistic relationship and it
used to be this balance but the people
that's the ability for the organization
to do that is constrained by the people
within that organization their own
individual abilities
to kind of switch between these two
these two systems and you know it's it's
kind of a lot yeah I guess you're
basically like the organization's
ability to do this runs up against the
biology of like the individuals and
their own ability to switch between
these different modes and I think it's
that ability to kind of run these two
modes in parallel is quite rare and it's
one thing to ask your leaders to have it
but to ask your entire organization to
have it it's like a whole much different
and much bigger ask and so one of my
things I keep thinking about when I'm
going through this book is like to what
extent does the full organization need
to have internalized like Duality
management or is it really just the
leaders or I think what Bajan would say
is like the board but I don't that
doesn't seem to connect each level of
the hierarchy like it seems like each
level of the hierarchy should be able to
manage these two different modes of
processing
but it's a rare skill so how is that
even possible to do
um yeah I'm not sure if you get any
thoughts on that
yeah a few more one is the
switching which is sometimes even
potentially like faster than a second
of our own behavior or neurophysiology
from task oriented to mind wandering
and to what extent we sometimes just
zone out thinking daydreaming reflecting
integrating looking at our schedule
looking at our inbox like it's not task
driven but that is like a space that can
then
transition into a task not always the
task we want but it can transition to a
task so that's kind of cool and
antagonistic's one way to frame it you
could also call them synergistic or
synergetic because they're part of that
Unity is plural and at minimum to angle
where no single neural network could be
tuned to be able to be both diffusive
and task oriented so why not have some
type of oscillatory process that enables
those two modes like having a forward in
a reverse in a car instead of trying to
make one gear that can do two things
that are contradictory
yeah it says super good point
um and in this paper they really uh
talked about
um they went in a greater detail about
the task positive Network and the
default mode Network and they said that
the task positive network is activated
during a broad range of non-social tasks
and is thought to be important for
problem solving focusing attention
making decisions and control of action
in other words for getting things done
however activation of the task positive
Network also has a deleterious effect on
other cognitive functions that are
essential to leadership it suppresses
activity in the
default mode Network
and similarly the default node mode
network plays a role in emotional
self-awareness social cognition and
ethical decision making it is also
strongly linked to creativity and
insightful problem solving and then the
activation of the default mode Network
they said elsewhere inhibits the the
task positive uh Network so I thought
that there's like this like neat and it
is like you know Unity you need both
um you can't constantly like be focused
on a task like you guys know how that
feels right like to just be like uh I'm
like out of it like you have to have
that like you need to like have work and
play
um in order for some kind of balance or
like it's it is unifying to be balanced
I think
just one thing that's made me remember I
think I've actually mentioned the same
previous stream but you know in regards
to like switching between the two Gears
of the car rather than trying to like
run them both at the same time one way
that this is was phrased to me by one of
my previous uh CEOs was you have like
art projects and you have science
projects and so like your art being your
default mode projects your science being
your task positive projects and like
explicitly saying like we are in art
mode right now like don't hold us
accountable to any metrics like this is
an art project we're exploring uh versus
science which is like hold me
accountable I mean and that means hold
me accountable to metrics like I'm going
to set a number and I'm going to hit
that number and like that's how you I
should be evaluated and so I think there
are ways you could probably like frame
switching between these modes in an
organization
yeah thank you Tyler and one biological
angle on this sometimes this type of
oscillation is called a winnerless
competition and it's modeled using
Predator prey type Dynamics uh Latka
Volterra is the name of the dynamical
formalism
and in the SPM textbook and package from
Carl friston and colleagues earlier work
there's a lot of examples of winnerless
competition lock of Volterra models
being used to model activity amongst
different brain regions and this
winnerless competition is an interesting
framing on everything from attention to
sleep it's like sleep is not trying to
be a hundred percent of the time
wakefulness is not trying to be 100 of
the time they inhibit each other
until there's a phase transition and
then it's like a dwell in one state and
then
that inhibition shifts and one
oscillates back and so similarly like a
predator doesn't over the long run
really want to eradicate the prey but
their populations fluctuate fluctuate
and that's a winnerless competition and
in fact that's a co-winning competition
and just one last Point
um I remember in the selfish Gene some
of the discussion of
out there on the Savannah look at the
cheetah eating the gazelle how can one
say that that's like a mammal level
selection at play that doesn't make any
sense it's like but actually if that
ecological relationship weren't there
then neither population would have the
resilience
so how we frame things and especially
the level of holism that we bring is
going to set the stage for whether we
see something as sustainable or
unsustainable adversarial or
non-adversarial
awesome
um
okay so moving on uh Bijan says free
energy governance is firmly rooted in
the belief that in a discontinuous and
distributed world the marginal benefit
of structural reorganizations as well as
structural compartmentalization of
exploitation and exploration are rather
sub-optimal or possibly
counterproductive competitiveness and
survival are increasingly determined by
the extent to which a system is rather
less rule or top-down supervised
learning based exploration happens
increasingly in real time within
exploitation in effect the emergence of
the new is essentially hypothesis
testing within the existing and I really
liked this like um uh like Daniel you
had mentioned earlier about like is this
a partition or is this like a nesting
um and like this exploration and
exploitation
um is like is a partition and also is
like a nesting
um based on on what Bijan says here uh
he also says in a distributed and
discontinuous Market environments the
real leadership challenge is to
de-antagonize the Past positive network
default mode Network dichotomy in the
form of Duality management
um do you guys have any comments here
all right
moving on do you want to read these
claims Tyler
sure feg's cross hierarchical
connectivity logically concludes that
managing the tpn DNN antagonism it's not
a top-down challenge calling for
structural compartmentalization but one
of Duality management by vacillating
between or among discrete formal
organization mode such as centralization
and decentralization the organization
may increase dynamically the levels of
exploration and exploitation Beyond
those achievable through an approach
based strictly on a static design Choice
summary
pretty much conceived organizing as an
informally deep learning and
self-designing Compass centralizing
intelligence at any hierarchical level
of the organization can be
counterproductive increasing free energy
promoting entropy and eventually
capitulating to tpn DMS and antagonistic
forces
um so I think one thing you might have
been referencing here is when you're
structurally trying to create you know
your DNN and tpn and like having them
separate from each other this is what's
like traditionally done in companies of
having like an r d department where like
this is where all the like the new ideas
come from
um and so it's I think he was
juxtaposing the fpg approach to like
that very traditional model
oh
um
so we'll move on here so he gives here
the free energy governance response to
the task positive network default mode
Network Challenge and it's this
three-fold response and he says
sensitizing the entire organization in
regard to Upper echelon's tendency to
top down extrapolating is dominant
supervising knowledge structures logic
and past experience as a guide and
prediction for future success a fallacy
that tasks specific exploitation tends
to reinforce embracing strategic renewal
as a matter of continuous deep learning
in the form of cultivating
cross-hierarchical processes empowering
purpose-directed and action-generated
bottom-up Market stimuli as a basis for
double Loop learning question the very
models that generate the top-down
predictions and three default abductive
attentional engagement at every level of
the organization forms the basis for
Effective top-down bottom-up prediction
error minimization after noticing an
environmental change it is essential to
question one's understanding of how the
subsystems of the environment EG
technology and markets and the
organization EG knowledge and goals are
linked without losing sight of the fact
that environment is not objectively
defined but a product of action
generated and socially constructed
shared meaning and expectations
so I think this is like how the Duality
management works essentially um that's
kind of what what I took from here Tyler
do you have comments
yeah and just that like these are all
really big asks to make up an
organization at every level like I think
it's one thing to say like yeah I agree
that this is the answer and if this
could be done like be like hell yeah
like I'm all for it but
I again feel like you're kind of running
up against people's individual abilities
to manage Duality just within themselves
um and that will constrain your ability
to do this with an organization
foreign
because I think about the cognitive cone
right like uh when we that we talked
about with Michael Levin and
um it's funny like
what you just said is like the flip of
the cognitive cone so usually it's like
the you know the the larger structure or
like the more top level hierarchical
structure will cognitively constrain
like things that are nested within it so
the shape of that cone the the shape of
the individual is within that cone can't
um be any other shape right like so they
can't come out of the cognitive cone of
the entire organization but but it's
interesting to think about how
um
what is happening at the individual
level like the shape of the individual
cognitive cone also uh lends itself to
the configuration of the higher level
cognitive cone the energy of comments I
see you're writing furiously no
all right
um drawing figures doodling seriously
um okay so bishan goes on to say talk
about a salience trap he says while
salience is critical to an active
inference it can nonetheless potentially
increase free energy to empower
abductive sense making so that weak
signals can serve as an infrari
information Rich enhancement to
predictions processing listening to it
wants to emerge organizational design is
challenged to neutralize the tendency of
experienced managers and board members
to overconfidently superimpose the
potential fallacy of their historic and
self-confidence-powered pattern
recognition since the human brains task
positive Network and default mode
Network spheres are antagonistically
related the only way to embrace
antagonism as Duality is by linking in
circular causality top-down predictions
and bottom-up stimuli
um and so here it's it I think that um
Bijan is really uh maybe kind of
criticizing or or like the maybe not
criticizing maybe uh
I don't know maybe criticizing's the
right word like how experience leads you
to prioritize like leads you to
um Place importance on things that and
maybe perhaps miss things that are
important in an Adaptive organization
I don't know do you guys have comments
here
we're drawn to the salience not to the
meaningful or adoptive necessarily we
hope that our salience
field can be aligned with what's
adaptive and meaningful but
I think we found out that that is not
always the case
and it's funny like I think about just
in scientific discovery right like how
we're so attuned we're looking for the
signal that we're looking for
um it takes like a very perceptive and
Adept scientist to not fall into that
salience trap and perhaps notice
um what's going on in the periphery
right like even though this is the
center this is what we're focusing on
there's a lot of peripheral things
happening that that might actually be
important or as important or maybe more
important than than the central thing
that we're focused on
um yeah I mean I guess that kind of the
other thing I say is that this is just
like another
it's one of those things where I agree
with this in Prince and like
theoretically but
there's so much stress going to like
many of these decisions like for example
if you have to do layouts for example
like it's very time sensitive and the
stakes are really high and so you know
going off your previous experience can
be really helpful in there because you
have to just make it really quick
decision and it's often like going to be
heuristic space uh which may be not
necessarily optimal but you really are
often constrained by like your time and
resources and like really processing all
of your bottom up seeing the signals
like even with the best intentions is
really hard to do
um and so again it's not to say like you
shouldn't try to do it or it can't be
done but it's just like
it's another one of these things we're
like hey this is a really big ass and I
just want to call out like this is
really really really really really hard
to do especially when you're under under
the gun
yeah let's see this is in the ideal
world this is how it would work right
um okay do you want to read this claim
first Tyler
sure
um all right so indeed this real-time
switching vacillation process cannot be
relegated to a single person if you need
a CEO or executive chairman or upper
echelon as a team but must be the result
of an unsupervised and FTP determined
learning process that relates to
top-down predictions and bottom of data
input circular causality to vacate
resource reconfiguration accordingly
consequently the board's potentially
unique dmn Dimension cannot be ignored
but must be integrated into the process
at the very top the board of directors
has given us cognitive diversity and
composition and cognitive distance firms
done at tpn exploitation Logics emerges
as a monitoring surveyor of the system
that is centered around managing the
dynamic interplay of dual forces
exploitation exploration and financial
and strategic controls
um yeah yeah something I thought that
was interesting here is that like
you know while he's making this claim
and which he's been through the whole
book that like pay the boards in this
really neat position to be just kind of
like an integrated unit
it kind of comes back to what we were
saying earlier of like okay who was
actually doing this do you want to be
management and so in one sense I'm like
okay it makes sense that the board would
be doing this because you can hold them
accountable to holding these different
ideas in their head at the same time uh
managing Duality but it seemed I would
think that you would need that Duality
management to be going down the
hierarchy not just at the border as well
and at each level the hierarchy is
managing duality in some sense
um
not from so I very much want to ask you
on that when we uh got on a call with
him
blue day one thing to add here
no
um but this is one sentence that I
pulled out randomly
um from the chapter that just like
struck me and like he just like threw it
in here and didn't unpack it through
anything the firm is the generative
social field and emerges in language and
I thought that this this was like really
profound so
um I don't know I just put it in here
because like just like wow that's very
deep
um I don't know
I don't know if you guys have comments
or this is something like I would ask
John to expand upon
you could ask a hundred people with
different backgrounds
what this invokes for them
and see where that goes
that sounds like a fun project it was
just like a like a sentence that seemed
very like yeah deep and like just
casually thrown in there yeah so I'm
gonna get this tattooed on my chest
right put it on your next business card
that'd be awesome that'd be an awesome
like statement for a business card right
um that'd be great
so what is it you say you do
I don't know I guess that's true this is
the business philosophy
awesome
so do you guys have any final like
comments questions Tyler did you tell us
all the things you wanted to tell us
no that's it for me
okay
yeah we're moving along through the
structure I'm looking forward to more
conversations and also some digestions
and Reflections making some schemes to
visualize at a high level what we've
been coming away from because this is
like our eighth session and I think
we're starting to see his patterns and
style of laying out what he wants to
convey and integrate
yeah I definitely think we're getting
like the repeat like repeat the message
and so so it's starting to drive some of
it home for me at least so coming up to
the end of the second part of the book
next week and I'll be looking forward to
that and um to hopefully discuss soon
with the author at his convenience that
that part
all right well thank you blue and Tyler
farewell
bye bye
next week same time